today we're going to go down into the
New York City subway set up a table on
the subway platform and see if we get
some strangers waiting for their trains
to play chess with us
hopefully we don't get kicked out too
fast by the cops
[Music]
I've never done this with chairs
all right I'm gonna see if I can get
anybody
sounds like he knows what he's doing a
little bit
it's for him it costs a hundred dollars
it's free
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good what is this project about
that's for chess.com okay
that's my move
I'll show this to the camera got the
chess.com app
you ever play on your phone oh yeah you
said he barely played what do you do for
work and Amazon uh you work at Amazon
yeah I take the packages you know put
them in the back so the truck could take
them and deliver it so I'm like the
professional term it's called stowing
what do you do for work Consulting like
what area of Consulting right now I'm in
financial services but it like changes
oh it's a plumber you're a plumber yeah
I'm a teacher what do you teach chess
I'm just kidding
self-defense you teach self-defense what
made you get into that I was in the
military so one of one of the few skills
I walked away with when did you retire
2010 my mother and my wife died within
two months and they couldn't handle it
here sorry to hear that how many hours a
week do you work nine to nine most days
nine to nine yeah I know 12 hour days
yeah wow you'd be surprised with some of
the people that are like a lot of my
friends that are in the investment
banking or something like that they're
working more hours in that each day and
they're working six days a week
are they happy
what part what branch of the military
were you in uh the Army I learned a lot
there was a unique experience of living
your life for a higher purpose
essentially a combination of really hard
work
Autumn and Terror I like living a boring
life you know I know a lot of people
don't like that you know they like going
out on the weekends or they like you
know hanging out with friends so I
reached out a timer on those for me huh
time down here doesn't exist that's a
move that's a good first move I just
felt it at the blunder on my part wow
I'm okay with that this is usually the
point in chess where I don't know what
to do what do you think about the state
of the world right now it's a beautiful
mess like it has its ups and downs but
it's a mess I didn't choose to live in
it but I'm making the best that I can
people are going crazy it's like
somebody released demons into the world
how do you stay sane I used to do a lot
of meditation take medication
you're doing consulting right now but
what's your dream job I could see myself
going to work like
at Patagonia or like something like that
I'd love to I'm like a huge nature
person Consulting is the opposite of
Patagonia I understand that yeah what's
like lesson 101 of self-defense run
what do you do if someone has a weapon
one hand blocks one hand strikes I like
you said that right as you made like a
perfect chess move what's that tattoo of
growing up I was a big anime fan like
you know Naruto got this of my family
with the Uchiha symbol and I got this so
this one it was a hard time in my life
you know I was a little suicidal and I
was like oh when I die bury me with a
couple rows have you ever seen a
celebrity on the streets of New York
yeah yeah like who Angela Lansbury
is that what does she want s okay
I eat lunch at my desk just so I can go
home as early as possible what are you
listening to right now what were you
listening to some good music I
downloaded Harry Styles
this man is listening to Harry Styles
you got train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran
Halo
you got Justin Bieber on here I'm a
Justin Bieber fan myself I know this may
seem obvious to other people what do you
do all day yeah so a lot of the
companies will come with us with like a
problem like they'll want to introduce a
new product or they'll uh they'll want
to try and restructure something on a
day-to-day basis we're helping them
solve those problems but what I'm doing
is I'm making PowerPoints I'm making
graphs in Excel graphs yeah yeah it's I
know it's super boring but somebody's
got to do it and the higher-ups aren't
going to do it they're the ones getting
the deals so yeah what are the higher
ups do losing yep they just Network the
thing is I have a bad bag and I can't
walk too much that's hard in New York
City well I don't really go out anymore
it hurts because I have a lady friend
that I that I talk to every day on the
phone she was there for me when my wife
died so
she wants me to go see her more often
but when we go out I can't keep up with
her because I have to keep stopping how
did you guys meet him she knew my wife
so she used to come around and tell me
talk to me I had to do this breakdown he
had me do work in her house like that we
got to know each other you know we
became real close we got a little bit
romantic for a little while and then
that didn't work out but we're still
friends have you ever had to defend
yourself in a situation other than being
in the military on 42nd Street years ago
I think he had one too many that night
what do you uh what are you most looking
forward to in life I want to start a
family that has been my dream ever since
I want to say I was like 10 years old
boy do I deserve that I wish we had a an
eval bar right now yeah I have no idea
where I'm at honestly what TV shows do
you usually watch
Ridiculousness ridiculate on MTV The
Unexplained science science films I like
those do you believe in aliens yeah
I have covered I'm sorry oh okay no
worries what is the meaning of life it's
funny because like what I'm doing I feel
like doesn't align with my philosophy on
what the meaning of life is but it's
like obviously spend as much time with
family as possible and just Chase
non-destructive forms of Serotonin like
just like try and be as happy as
possible be the best person you can be
get closer to God not to be evil to each
other what do you think the meaning of
life is
the people in your life if there's any
advice I could give anybody whatever
happens happens not to be dark but
eventually you know you're gonna die you
don't know what happens after you die so
whatever you do now do it because you
want to you know live your life as free
as you possibly can check why you got me
good Little Fork action is that
Checkmate I think that's Checkmate dude
enjoy the rest of your trip I think we
taught our chess I think you got me
I'll see you in a self-defense class I
hope you make it out of Consulting and
uh into I hope you're the CEO of
Patagonia someday oh don't forget your
phone
enjoy Harry Styles
[Music]